i must be the worst correspondent people
don't worry i am not quitting my day job
so you guys have nothing to worry about
let's talk about 90210 this just might
not be the right move for me
you know you're right i didn't want to
do it what's the most important thing
that you want people to know about you i
think that like
that i'm good
first of all i have to apologize that
entertainment tonight sent this
correspondent to she's a little
unprofessional i'm super disappointed
i mean this is gonna be rough yeah let's
see let's see how this goes i think the
first thing that
people always ask me about you and i
don't like speaking for other people so
what's the most important thing that you
want people to know about you
oh um i'm gonna throw you a curveball
right at it i mean yeah you definitely
just just threw one right at me um i
don't know i think that like
that i'm good i think that that's
sort of i i i love it when people say
you know we're praying for you
and everything else but there comes a
point where you go
i'm i got this like i'm fine i'm good
um there's a lot of people in the world
that
that could use prayers and
i'm feeling great you know i have an
amazing medical team behind me
and and you can let me in an exercise
class so i have a few okay friends and
stuff so
uh you know i'm doing okay i'm doing
really i'm doing better than okay i'm
doing well like i feel
strong and healthy and confident
and happy and is that why you chose to
share your diagnosis
the original reason why i chose to share
the diagnosis was a little bit more
convoluted it was
part of a lawsuit it was going to come
up anyway
and i didn't want some big insurance
corporation that doesn't really care
about human beings
controlling like my narrative and
controlling my story
and because it is my story
the reason why i continue to share more
is i want to really push for
education and awareness and
raise more money and i also want people
to not
hear stage four cancer and think of the
person that
you know is gray and falling over you
get written off so quickly
even though you're still vital and
healthy and happy and
wanting to you know go out there and
work so i'm
sharing in order to give hopefully a
different face
to to all of this i can attest that
there's nothing you can't do
thanks well
a special correspondent i'm supposed to
talk about the people in your life that
have helped you get through this time so
i'm thinking specifically they're asking
about me
but it actually doesn't say that it
actually says specifically your mom and
kurt which i think has to be a misprint
on it
completely yeah i mean right how have i
been i'm kidding
uh but what i'll joking aside
do you appreciate that i'm not talking
at all
it's really about me that's why we're
all here guys uh do you
uh the thrills are really good for
correspondence too on journalists i
think they really recommend the use of
the word
uh life makes you sound really
intelligent
how have you found the support from the
people around you and how do you feel on
the street when someone comes up to you
support from uh
my family my friends my loved ones i
mean my
my friends are my family right so um
has been phenomenal and you know
obviously you know how supportive that
you've been anne-marie
chris um obviously my mom has been a
huge support my husband
um and let's not forget about bowie
who's been like
the best dog ever who for some reason my
son is convinced as a boy
even though we all know bowie is a girl
he's a girl and now we're
seven eight years in and he's still
calling a boy but you know i think that
and and people coming up to me
the fact that my story and my diagnosis
has maybe reached somebody else or
or helped them get through it because
we we all just sort of focus only on the
person
with the cancer but there's everybody
else
as well there is that support system
there is how how is it impacting my mom
how is it impacting my husband how is it
impacting my friends how is it impacting
other you know strangers who don't know
me but they
feel like they are connected to me it
it goes back to that question how do i
feel about the why me
this is a perfect example of why me
because i'm
able to have a platform
and with that platform i'm actually able
to
reach more people and possibly help them
and touch them
along with really
bringing more thought
into the cancer community direct them to
a website like standuptocancer.org for
example
it's directing people there to say hey
you can get support you can get help
um just because you're not the one with
cancer doesn't mean that you're not
going through something emotional
i mean talking about sort of
people that don't actually have the
cancer but their family member does or
their friend
how and knowing the impact that that has
how how has this impacted you
i never want to be the narrator for
somebody else's story so i don't
ever like answering for you but people
come up to me all the time and they ask
me about you and with such genuine
concern and all i can think about
is that effect that you have that people
feel like i know for
you know i went through brenda falling
in love or i went through this
and i actually literally did because i
knew you and i was your friend and so i
see the impact that that has on people
and i know
the ability that you have to reach
people and so i'm so
proud how public you've been about it
but i also understand reading a room and
knowing that sometimes there are times
in your life where you don't want people
to come up to you
and i'm happy to sort of be that buffer
so
a lot of people have asked me questions
about the dinner and how you chose to
reveal
to your closest family and friends well
i mean so it was
i i just got diagnosed and uh
and yeah i wanted the closest people in
my life to have
to be told but not just be told of
because i'm the type of person i just
call you and be like listen i got stage
four
it's back and i'll be okay but i knew
that particularly someone like you would
have more questions
and so for me to have dr pirro my
oncologist be there so that he could
answer the questions in a much more
you know very matter-of-fact way
so i think it was just it was more to
help you guys not that this is about me
but since i clearly like to make
everything about me
i think for me the biggest learning
experience through all of this is the
education
yeah and not being afraid to ask
questions and i think that's the hardest
thing is you never know as the friend
the family what is your place what are
you supposed to do i think asking
questions
is imperative and i never look at it as
as you're bothering me or i don't want
to answer these or i get uncomfortable
i would rather somebody ask me or
a a a doctor with a medical degree
who's fantastic questions as opposed to
having questions and then just going
onto google because there's so much
misinformation or information that's
true for
you know a particular kind of cancer or
the way that you know your cancer
travels
coastal there's there's so many
different
uh things that go into
how a person's body is reacting and
dealing with cancer
and people don't consider that so they
instantly just think it's a it's a death
sentence and it's not it's not
yeah i mean i like to think i'm an md
but i think it stands for mom doctor not
actually
pretty sure it's not actual md yes yes
okay how about
how about your biggest fear what's your
biggest fear
ground squirrels eating the rest of my
vegetable garden that
is really bothering me too by the way
you missed
all the heirloom tomatoes because those
squirrels
ate all of them and what was really
weird is that
it started with like five and then i
felt like they have this underground
network well it's like a full like yeah
it's like a connection so it was like a
million
within a day a million showed up so yeah
ground squirrels were my biggest fear at
this point
we are warrior sisters in this fight and
please make no mistake about it
this is an urgent fight we need to stand
up to cancer
to keep pushing the boundaries let's
talk about stand up to cancer just for a
second here
i'm sure every advocacy group in the
world would want you to represent them
why that group i'm an ambassador for
stand up to cancer and
stand up to cancer they're leading the
charge
in research they have clinical trials
going on
currently um they have been
part of a drug that got fda approved for
cancer
they raise a huge amount of money
awareness advocacy they have
support teams that can help again not
just the person with cancer
but families as well so for me when
i look at stand up to cancer
the amount of education that they're
putting out there
for instance early testing i mean it's
so important just realize that
getting diagnosed early is going to help
save your life
and again it's all information that
standupcancer.org
has their website is fantastic it's
super informative
i can attest to someone who went and got
their mammogram during covet
how safe it feels and the protocols that
are in place
and that it is one of those things that
is not worth putting off in this
environment
a lot of people ask me too like how has
the pandemic affected
you and the way i mean i know the answer
is it hasn't because
if anything it gives us a better excuse
to hole up and yeah and not have to be
social
right as you know i've been training for
this my entire life
uh i'm i'm essentially shut in to begin
with
so this has felt amazing
and uh the only person to answer that
question that way yes
i mean you know for me it's it's
all the things that i've been
uncomfortable with for a while
like shaking hands and the two to two
like hugs with strangers i hope shaking
hands never comes back it's just not
sanitated
it's never gonna come back i think
i think if it does we always for now
have an excuse to
not do it um
you know there have been in all
seriousness with the pandemic yes
it has been somewhat easy for me just
because i love staying home
and i recognized before they were sort
of saying hey
go into quarantine i recognize that
there was a problem i started
quarantining
way sooner than most people did but with
that being said i also
didn't go in for my blood panel for
probably three months and you're
supposed to go in once a month
i resisted because i didn't want to be
in a doctor's office i didn't want to go
to a clinic i didn't want to be exposed
there are many cancer patients whose
whose
treatments have been altogether
cancelled
chemo radiation just canceled there are
people who can't even make it in there
anymore
and for that i think the pandemic has
been
extremely extremely difficult and
we we sort of i see those people walking
around who they still don't want to wear
a mask or they wear the mask down here
they wear the mask down here and i'm
like okay
i understand that you're annoyed that
you have to wear a mask but
let's think about the people who are
just trying to pick up something to eat
that's healthy
who needs to be in chemo and they can't
even get to their chemo appointment
anymore
let's think about those people let's
think about you know our elders let's
immune compromised um so
so what i really do recognize is how
incredibly difficult the pandemic has
been on
anybody with any sort of debilitating
disease i did a movie in japan a very
long time ago and that was when i was
first introduced to masks and it was in
the winter and it's very cold in japan
and at one point i got sick and i they
told me to put my mask on and i wore my
mask and i infected
nobody none of my co-stars nobody and i
thought this is amazing
like i could not i didn't transmit the
common cold on and i still was able to
do my regular day and i thought
years ago i was like how is that not a
thing here right
yes i mean we could really really use
some of those
plus this whole not having to do my
makeup except for like some mascaras
as a woman it's amazing i mean it's
genius i
between the mask and then a baseball hat
sunglasses few
you could be me i could be you nobody
wouldn't know okay so
let's talk about 90210 for the fans out
there maybe actually this is just really
a question for me because we've
got it too hey guys
tori said that you might be needing my
help well hello
wow hello i think i know you originally
hesitant
to do the reboot and i know that there
might have been someone sitting
right here that really also forced you
to do it because
they wanted to see you in it right i
didn't want to do it um
and you know i mean i have my own
reasons for not wanting to do it one of
them is
i've played the character so many times
and i've done so many
versions of 90210 that it just felt
um it felt like we had really exhausted
that avenue
and um and i believe in
leaving
people like less is more sometimes and
you want to leave people
wanting to see a show as opposed to
being oh my god i hope that never comes
back on the air
so i was just a little trepidatious and
um
and someone very important to me uh
passed away
and and i got my diagnosis
and it was all sort of within a couple
of months together and
it just made me give pause and
and rethink it and yes it was a way to
honor luke
which was important to me but it was
also a way to
i don't want to say honor myself but to
how about honor your fans honor my fans
but i think it was a way to
honor my cancer family by
saying hey yeah yeah
like nobody's gonna know but at least
when it comes out that i have stage four
i will have been able to say yes but i
worked throughout it
i was just gonna say that so i had so
many friends that were crew members and
everyone kept saying
oh my goodness shannon is the most
professional she just like these hours
were so long and like no one hits their
marks and i was like yep that's my girl
yeah i mean you know like you still i'm
i'm able to work a 16
18 hour day i'm not i don't think
anyone's watching i am not
able to do it i never think you should
like 18 hours is always a little
ridiculous
but there are moments when it's required
so um
so i think for all of those reasons and
then
and then actually being there and
knowing that i was gonna have
sort of a voice in what at least my
character did
so bringing the fun side
and i think pretty much like 90 percent
of
everything that came out of my mouth was
improv none of it was scripted
um i can attest to that yeah i just you
know
looked at scripts hey you know like i
mean brian and i were
and i and you we were all sort of just
improving and throwing stuff out there
and
and to have that freedom that everybody
allowed us to have
to do that and to sort of embrace it and
let us
run with it was was wonderful i can
actually say like
that was that was an excellent
experience
in that department to to actually be in
a show where you can just sort of improv
and
and and be that creative and free did
your kids like buffy
or 90210 better my kids are too young
for 90210 although charlotte has like
been
begging for nineveh what about charms so
we're so they're just finishing buffy
and they're getting ready to start the
first three years of chart okay so we're
gonna
and only the first three years then
we're gonna just turn it off
there wasn't more than three years right
i don't know well there's three years at
a reboot
okay something i must be the worst
correspondent because
most of these questions are about me
well don't worry i am not quitting my
day job so you guys have nothing to
worry about are there questions about
you
there's a few uh okay here's one what do
you think about my early morning texts
asking you to work out annoying or
inspiring
how many times have i asked you about
friday already i would say
it's uh uh
a noise spur can we make up a new word
fair that's fair it's annoying and
inspiring um
no it's it's it's not annoying or
inspiring right i mean like you work out
i'm kind of annoying i work out it's all
i have right now
and it's the only thing i can do i'm
super appreciative
that you know i can go work out with you
and
that you know emery comes over and works
out with me like it's great i
i need a little extra push sometimes to
work out
um because i'd rather just go lay by the
pool or work in my garden
so mine is the squirrels the ground
squirrels uh minus grass wait ground
squirrels or are there air squirrels
like what's that what's that what's
the ground squirrels are the ones that
like dig holes
okay and then there was other ones that
aren't treats i should clarify i'm a new
yorker
the squirrels are just the people in
central park i don't i mean aren't there
flying
squirrels like they're squirrels that
like fly on cartoons
for sure no no in real life i've seen
that
do you know what they did oh my wait
squirrels fly
no i think that's like a cartoon if you
look before you leave today i'll show
you
um they literally climbed up my avocado
trees
and took all the avocados down there was
literally like 30 avocados and they take
a tiny little bite
and then they leave it see that's just
rude so if you're going to take my
avocado like
the whole thing this is the whole thing
okay i got one for our wine tik tok
[Music]
challenge
who do you think was better that's a
terrible question that's a terrible
question because you can't wait we're
not answering that
but how was the practice it's teamwork
it's teamwork it is
teamwork we were both excellent and we
were both
dedicated to the cause it's a good thing
i'm not quitting my day job boy
what's your favorite thing about your
your friendship with sarah
notice that they're asking what's your
favorite thing about your friendship
with sarah because this terrible
correspondent will not ask that question
my favorite thing about my friendship
with sarah is
definitely your children yeah um they're
i found something right they are now
like my children
um i love them madly it's even better
than having my own children because
i take them home and you take the week
at the end of the weekend um
no they're i mean your kids are
fantastic but i think i think
even more than your children is the fact
that
and this is probably the one time i'll
start getting emotional which is really
funny
is your support but it's not just your
support
it's your intelligence so it's so nice
for me
to have a female friend
that feels no threat
no jealousy we both have never felt that
with each other we've done
nothing but lift each other up and
support each other in our careers
and champion one another but to be able
to sit down and have
the kind of intelligent conversations
that we have
i that to me is the most precious thing
about the two of us this is so
uncomfortable right now
what is your favorite thing about your
friendship with me
oh no on the table oh no the tables are
tables
what is your favorite thing about me and
your friendship
with me
i just i've only i have a very
small group of female friends that i've
had since
childhood and i haven't had the easiest
time
working with a lot of women and it's
never been the most positive but to have
a friend like you that has my back no
matter
what i mean first of all i always have
an alibi so that's the first thing
but to have someone that believes in me
the way you do when i don't believe in
myself
and that shows me how to fight for the
things that are important to me
and the things that i want and the
things that i deserve who makes me laugh
who's always willing to try any
ridiculous challenge that i bring
yes we need a new one we do need a new
challenge
i just and then this industry on top of
it where women are so often pitted
against each other
and it's not about supporting other
women to have someone that i know
loves me for me not who i am not
just like that this is so awkward this
is why this is why
i don't ask these questions um but i'm
very lucky and
the one thing that i will say about this
journey is that i love that for the
first time
other people see the shannon that i've
known all these years
and you've always been so tough and you
put this exterior out and
the vulnerable side of shannon is
something that i've known my whole life
but i like that that other people get to
see this thank you just
and you cook really well and i had him
she's a really good cook
any relationship whether it's husband
wife friends
it's all about communication
and being there for the other person and
that's a two-way street so
my actual strength doesn't come from me
it comes from you
and vice versa see i mean i think that
that's the thing about when you find
that friend is that you when you find
your people
you you just you feed off of each other
in a very positive way and i will say
that
as hard and difficult as 2020 has been
and quarantined the upside has been
the strengthening in the relationships
that i have been able
to really either physically be with or
emotionally be with during this
because time is slower and i
feel closer to you this year
i think that that slow down has been
really beneficial to
those relationships and growing those
relationships i agree i mean covet is
you know it's a lot of i still wanted to
go away a lot of people and we wanted to
go away and
you know there are those people that
have passed from it
and it's horrific and there's um
you know you just pray for their for
their families but
it's also been a reset for a lot of
people
and resetting sort of your priorities
and what matters in life
my biggest fear is that it's going
people are just gonna forget
and where that reset is going to just go
away so i'm really
really really really hoping that we all
remember
this time period and what it was like
and the fact that we did get closer
with our families we did get maybe we
made the time to sit down and have
family dinners when before we weren't
able to
i don't think that we'll forget because
i know that some of these traditions
like
saturday night dinner and some of those
things i
i couldn't live my life without them
there are so many things in covet i've
learned to live without
but those are the moments but those
moments are forever
[Music]